two Russian former convicts who claimed
that they served as commanders for the
ragno mercenary group have apparently
confessed to committing war crimes in
Ukraine including the killing of
children in an hour-long video with the
Russian human rights organization they
said the acts took place in solidar and
bakmut
um
return
Ed
again
foreign
well since the video emerged the alleged
commanders of the Wagner group claimed
that they were blackmailed and paid to
make the Confessions by the Russian
Human Rights group that they spoke to
while defense and security analyst
Michael Clarke joins me now
um it's desperately murky and it's
desperately upsetting isn't it Michael
it's about a proper Gander war with both
sides making claims and counter claims
what's your take on it
yes Jane um I mean certainly what they
say these uh two characters Savage what
they say certainly seems uh plausible
and it it Accords with what we know
happened in solidar and back but whether
the particular things they say
cross-reference to a particular
incidence we don't yet know although we
may find out but it is more curious as
to wonder
um why are they saying it now they
they've not been taken prisoners so they
wouldn't necessarily be saying things to
please the ukrainians they're not
outside Russia they're inside Russia
making apparently confessions of war
crimes to a human rights organization
what do they want I mean you know are
they trying to be big names they're
trying to be celebrities in some way
that's a strange thing to do do you
believe they've been blackmailed by a
Human Rights group that's very hard to
imagine and what they are uh confessing
to are war crimes and the point is if
they were convicts working for Wagner
they do have a very powerful mitigation
because in Wagner's Playbook if you're a
convict can you disobey an order they
will shoot you out of hand they always
said that and they've done it and that's
powerful mitigation but it doesn't Wipe
Out the war crime the mitigation can be
as powerful as you like the war crime is
a war crime and that means almost
certainly on the basis of what they've
said they will be indicted by the
international criminal court which means
that in 123 countries around the world
they would be arrested if they were
known to be there if they turned up on
holiday anytime in the next 30 or 40
years so they probably now can't leave
Russia so why are they saying we don't
know but I I suspect we'll hear more
about this story in the days to come
what do you make of the announcement by
ministers today that about these Russian
line groups that they could be posing a
new cyber security threat for the UK
yes I mean this has been coming for some
time I mean the Russians have been
targeting uh Britain through these
groups they're the um uh group group
called apt uh uh 29 uh which is quite an
important Group which is an a persistent
threat group uh 29 which is giving rise
to Crazy Bear and dancing bear and all
sorts of other groups who appear to be
private but actually they're not they're
run by the Russian State and they've
targeted uh British facilities in the
past and we talk about uh critical
National infrastructure what does it
mean well these are the 13 sectors of
Britain's critical National
infrastructure as defined by the
government and listed listed
alphabetically from chemical civil
nuclear communication right through to
transport space and water and we've
color-coded them a bit the the the light
blue sectors are the ones that the
government obviously control the
obviously control defense they obviously
Control emergency services and
government and they have a big say in
obviously in health not all of it but
but large parts of health and large
parts of space but the other areas
chemical or Finance or energy or water
transport these are all in private
sector hands and so the government can
control some parts of the critical
National infrastructure but they have to
just try to influence the other parts
and what I think the government were
doing today was in a sense opening up a
new campaign to influence the part of
the cni structure that they don't
control to behave in a way that's more
Vigilant about the threats which are
undoubtedly coming down the line of
cyber disruption
turn into latest on the ground in
Ukraine what's the latest there
yes well in Ukraine we're all waiting
for the big offensive the spring
offensive that the ukrainians are
believed to conduct but we all always
look at the weather it's going to be wet
for the next two weeks in these in the
areas that we're interested in and that
means that the ukrainians almost
certainly won't go until the ground is a
bit more dry for their armored forces so
I think this probably means that nothing
much will happen in the next 10 days to
two weeks but after that a lot will
happen and a lot of that what will
happen will depend on what happens at
Ramstein on Friday of this week the
Allies were of our supplying Ukraine
more than 50 different countries will
meet for one of their regular meetings
at the Ramstein Air Base in Germany the
American Air Base and there they will
discuss what the ukrainians need and
what we know they need more than
anything else at the moment is probably
air defense air defense missiles they
say they haven't got enough they say
it's desperate and believe me they will
not want to start their offensive until
they can control the skies above their
ground forces that will be the critical
issue which will be being discussed I
suspect on Friday